well individuals are
citizens and can come right in and
encourage things and speak out on write
op-eds and papers and so forth there
also voters so they in touch with their
individual congressman and a lot of them
are also shareholders either through
mutual funds or otherwise of automobile
companies utilities the other day I just
got an email from a solar company that
says you know Connecticut in New York
have great provisions for integrating
rooftop solar into their grid and
Pennsylvania just won't hear of it well
you know you can if you're a shareholder
of Pennsylvania utilities you can get in
touch with them and say hey what's
what's with you guys so there are
various things I think that one can do
there is an outfit to call plug-in
partners then that's their their URL wtm
plug-in partners dot org I think that is
taking soft orders for plugins to ship
off to automobile companies and so forth
so that no one can say there's not an
interest in in plugins I as you can tell
I genuinely think plugins are going to
have a huge impact once people realize
that they can not only go into a
showroom and buy a reasonably priced car
that they can plug into their garage
socket drive for much of the day on
effectively penny a mile electricity
because off-peak overnight power is
about a nickel a kilowatt hour in much
of the country five kilowatt hour charge
so say it's something between one and
two cents a mile nonetheless gasoline
now is 10 12 14 cents a mom so you're
driving it's something close to
one-tenth the cost that you're usually
driving that that makes a big difference
in some people's budgets and the other
thing is that there's a concept called
v2g or vehicle to grid which after
you've charged your plugin
I bread let's say you get it charged by
midnight have a timer on it you can make
it available to the utility from
midnight to 6am when let's say you leave
for work for stabilization of the grid
and for what's called spinning reserves
that is power outages those two together
are only about 5% of what utilities need
to buy about about 12 billion dollars a
year worth of fossil fuels mainly
natural gas because natural gas tends to
be what is turned on and off quickly
since its amenable to that well you know
that amount of money if it's divided up
fairly between the utilities and the and
the consumers there's a professor at the
University of Delaware kimpton who is
writing articles about this and saying
you know you realize that could be
something up in the range of two
thousand dollars a year for the owner of
a plug-in hybrid now let's think about
this a minute not only am i driving at a
tenth the cost but somebody's paying me
close to two hundred dollars a month
heck that's a major share of my car
payment just to leave my car plugged in
overnight hey where is that dealer
showroom you know so I think once and
and different utilities are interested
in this to different degrees but in
California if you talk to PG&E for
example they are really enthusiastic
about this concept so there could be an
extension interest in a lot of people in
in moving toward plug-in hybrids once
are available